No one goes to Hank's for his spreadsheets. They go for a darn good pizza. Lately, though, the shop's been quiet. So Hank decides to bring back the $1 slice. He asks Copilot in Microsoft Excel to look at his sales and costs. Help him see if he can afford it. Co-pilot shows Hank where the money's going and which little extras make the dollar slice work.
没有人会为了汉克的电子表格而去他那儿，他们去是为了吃上一块绝佳的披萨。不过最近，店里变得有些冷清。于是汉克决定重新推出一美元一块的披萨。他让微软 Excel 中的 Copilot 来查看他的销售额和成本。帮他看看自己是否承担得起。Copilot 向汉克展示了资金的去向，以及哪些小配菜能让一美元披萨的方案可行。
Now, Hank has a line out the door. Hank makes the pizza. Co-Pilot handles the spreadsheets. Learn more at M365Copilot.com slash work. Are you and your job just not clicking anymore? Maybe a toxic coworker is making your life miserable, or maybe you're trying to figure out why you're not getting promoted, or why your workload is suddenly out of control.
现在，汉克店门口排起了长队。汉克负责做披萨，Copilot 负责处理电子表格。访问 M365Copilot.com slash work 了解更多信息。你是不是觉得你和你的工作越来越合不来了？也许某个有毒的同事让你的生活苦不堪言，或者你正在琢磨为什么自己总是升不了职，又或者为什么你的工作量突然失控了。
Or perhaps you're wondering whether you're even in the right field. Maybe it's time to change not just jobs, but your career. Today I'm going to talk to an expert in the science of work and workplace communication about how to handle tough career situations like these, and why improving communication with your coworkers, bosses, and others is the key to finding a successful and satisfying career. So what should you do when your job isn't working for you? If you're considering a job or career change,
或者，你可能在想自己是不是根本选错了行业。也许是时候不仅换个工作，还要换个职业了。今天我将与一位职场科学和职场沟通领域的专家聊聊，如何处理这些棘手的职业困境，以及为什么改善与同事、老板及其他人的沟通是找到一份成功且满意的职业的关键。那么，当工作不再顺心时，你该怎么办？如果你正在考虑换工作或转行，
how can you figure out why you're dissatisfied with your work and what could be a better fit? How can you handle toxic coworkers or avoid getting stuck with them in the first place? And overall, how can you find fulfilling work where you will thrive? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills.
你该如何找出自己对工作不满意的原因，以及什么才是更适合你的选择？你该如何应对有毒的同事，或者从一开始就避免被他们纠缠？总而言之，你该如何找到能让自己大展身手、实现自我价值的满意工作？欢迎收听“心理学对话”（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客节目，旨在探讨心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。
My guest today is Dr. Tessa West, a professor of psychology at New York University. Dr. West studies the science of interpersonal communication in many contexts, including in the workplace. Her latest book published in July is called Job Therapy, Finding Work That Works for You, and her previous book published in 2022 is Jerks at Work, Toxic Co-workers and What to Do About Them. Dr. West's research has examined questions such as how status differences between people shape how they behave, why it's so hard to give honest critical feedback, how class, race, and cultural differences can make communication in the workplace difficult. and what can we do to improve it? She has published dozens of research studies and received
我今天的嘉宾是纽约大学（New York University）心理学教授苔丝·韦斯特博士（Dr. Tessa West）。韦斯特博士研究多个背景下的人际沟通科学，包括职场环境。她于 7 月出版的新书名为《工作疗法：找到适合你的工作》（Job Therapy, Finding Work That Works for You），她于 2022 年出版的前一本书是《职场中的混蛋：有毒的同事以及如何应对他们》（Jerks at Work, Toxic Co-workers and What to Do About Them）。韦斯特博士的研究探讨了诸如人与人之间的地位差异如何塑造他们的行为、为什么给出诚恳的批判性反馈如此艰难、阶级、种族和文化差异如何使职场沟通变得困难等问题，以及我们能做些什么来改善这些状况？她发表了数十项研究成果，并获得了
multiple grants from the National Science Foundation and the National Institutes of Health. Her work has been covered by media outlets, including Scientific American, the New York Times, and CNN, to name just a few. Dr. West, thank you for joining me today. Thank you so much for having me on the show. Your new book is called job therapy, but you're a research psychologist yourself, not a therapist. Why did you decide that framework of therapy was a good way to look at work and career issues? You know, it's interesting. I actually kind of came around to this idea studying close relationships, studying romantic relationships and relationships we have with our family members, our children and our parents. And at New York University, where I work, I've been teaching
国家科学基金会（National Science Foundation）和美国国立卫生研究院（National Institutes of Health）的多项资助。她的工作受到了各大媒体的报道，其中包括《科学美国人》（Scientific American）、《纽约时报》（The New York Times）和 CNN 等等。韦斯特博士，非常感谢你今天能来参加我们的节目。非常感谢邀请我来节目。你的新书名叫《工作疗法》，但你自己是一位研究型心理学家，而不是治疗师。为什么你认为“疗法”这个框架是看待工作和职业问题的好方法？你知道，这很有趣。其实我是在研究亲密关系、浪漫关系以及我们与家人、孩子和父母的关系时，慢慢萌生出这个想法的。在纽约大学，也就是我工作的地方，我一直在教授
a course on close relationships for about 15 years. And I started to see a lot of overlap between mean the ways people were talking about their workplace issues, the emotions that they were feeling, you know, complex things like ambivalence, loving and hating your job at the same time, trends around interviewing like ghosting and icing and these kinds of things. These same things were things that I've been teaching in the context of romantic relationships and concepts that therapists that therapists in that space have been grappling with for a really long time and helping people kind of get their head around. And I thought, why not adopt something? some of those therapeutic perspectives, some of the things that we know help people through difficulties
关于亲密关系的课程大约有 15 年了。我开始发现人们谈论职场问题的方式、他们感受到的情绪之间有很多重叠之处，你知道，比如矛盾心理这样复杂的事情——同时爱着和恨着你的工作，面试中的一些趋势比如“失踪”（ghosting）、“冷落”（icing）以及诸如此类的事情。这些同样的事情也是我一直在浪漫关系语境中教授的内容，并且是该领域的治疗师们长期以来一直在努力应对、并帮助人们理清头绪的概念。我想，为什么不把其中的一些
in their interpersonal relationships to our relationships with our career. Now, in the book, you outline five key drivers that make people consider leaving their jobs. Can you talk briefly about those? Yes, I actually started with the toughest kind of most existential one, which is having an identity crisis at work. This idea that you can just fall out of love with something. that has been defining you for a really long time, that your core sense of who you are as a person, your identity as a human being, is very much wrapped up in your workplace identity,
治疗视角，把我们所知道的能够帮助人们度过人际关系困境的方法，应用到我们与职业的关系中去呢？在书中，你概述了导致人们考虑离职的五个关键驱动因素。你能简要谈谈这些因素吗？是的，我实际上是从最艰难、最存在主义的一种开始的，那就是在工作中经历身份危机。这种观点认为，你可能会对某个长期定义你、让你作为一个人对自己的核心认知以及作为人类的身份与职场身份紧密相连的事物，
but you're starting to question that. And I think people who go through this are often very advanced in their careers. They've spent a lot of time and money getting there. They have a lot of status. And so kind of grappling with falling out of love with something that still defines you is a common experience among our kind of more well-seasoned career goers out there. From there, I talk about being drifted apart from your job. And this is a little bit like looking over at your spouse and thinking, who are you? You are not the person that I'm married, that I initially got into this romantic relationship with. I don't recognize you.
不知不觉就失去了爱意，但你开始对此产生怀疑。我认为经历这一过程的人通常在职业生涯中处于相当高级的阶段。他们花费了大量时间和金钱才走到这一步。他们拥有很高的地位。因此，努力去接受自己不再爱那个依然定义着自己的事物，是那些比较成熟的职场人士中一种常见的经历。在此之后，我谈到了与工作渐行渐远。这有点像看着你的配偶，然后想：你是谁？你根本不是我结婚的那个人，不是我最初开始这段浪漫关系时的那个人。我认不出你了。
And when we go through this experience, a lot of us think that it's really the other person or in this kind of metaphor, the career that's changed. It's not so much us. And so their journey is really about understanding who's changed, you know, and how much I have changed. and often we change, not for the better or the worst, but in different ways and parallel ways. I also talk about this kind of idea of being spread too thin. And I think, you know, this chapter of the book is really for everybody, even if you're not
当我们经历这种体验时，我们中的很多人会认为真正改变的是对方，或者在这个隐喻中，是职业变了。并不是我们变了多少。所以他们的这段心路历程实际上是去理解到底是谁变了，你知道的，以及我自己变了多少。而且通常我们的改变并不是朝着更好或更坏的方向，而是朝着不同且平行的方向。我还谈到了这种“分身乏术”的想法。我认为，你知道的，书中的这一章其实适合每一个人，即使你并没有
having a career crisis. I think we are in an age of sort of unprecedented busyness. We often take on roles and tasks that really aren't actually helping us advance in our careers and we're not quite sure why. We tasks switch all the time. Probably your listeners are familiar with checking their. phones or their emails or ordering groceries while on work calls. This seems to be sort of the norm rather than the exception. And helping people kind of deal with those everyday little issues
面临职业危机。我认为我们正处于一个前所未有的忙碌时代。我们经常承担那些实际上并没有真正帮助我们在职业生涯中取得进展的角色和任务，而且我们并不十分清楚原因。我们一直在不停地切换任务。你的听众可能对一边开着工作会议，一边查看手机、邮件或网购杂货并不陌生。这似乎已经成了常态，而不是特例。帮助人们应付那些日常的小问题，
that are preventing them from feeling good about their jobs, but also moving ahead. And then the last two chapters of the book aren't about falling out of love with your job, but about your job not loving you back. And I think for those of us who've ever been a runner-up at work, we struggle with getting a promotion or raise, but we don't know why. That can be a really frustrating experience. And I've learned that often kind of comes down to huge communication gaps between what promoters tell you, or at least they think they're implying what you should be doing to get ahead and what you think you should be doing. They're often misaligned. I end with the underappreciated star. This is the person who brings a lot to the workplace and they get a lot of paths on the back.
正是这些问题阻碍了他们对工作产生良好感觉，同时也阻碍了他们向前迈进。然后，书的最后两章关心的不是你不再爱你的工作，而是你的工作没有回馈你的爱。我想，对于我们这些曾在职场中当过“陪跑者”的人来说，我们在争取升职或加薪时苦苦挣扎，却又不知为何。那可能是一段非常令人沮丧的经历。而我了解到，这通常归结为巨大的沟通鸿沟：晋升决策者告诉你（或者至少他们以为自己在暗示）你应该做些什么才能高升，与你认为自己应该做些什么之间，往往存在错位。最后我以“被低估的明星”结尾。这类人为职场带来了很多贡献，他们也得到了很多鼓励。
They get a lot of nice Slack channel messages and, you know, emails, but they're not rewarded in the ways they care about. And I think kind of one struggle for these folks is really getting down at the bottom of the question is, does my industry even care about stars? You know, is there even a market for someone with my level of expertise that costs as much as I do, or is good enough just fine? And I became very cynical in doing research for this book that often the answer is good enough is fine, and that's why you're not getting what you want. But it's really all about sort of loving something that isn't giving those things back to you that you feel like you're giving to that job or to that career. Should we really expect to be in love with our jobs? I mean, it is work after all, and we have
他们收到了很多温馨的 Slack 频道消息和电子邮件，但他们并没有得到他们真正在乎的那种回报。我认为这类人群所面临的一个挣扎，其实是去探究这个底层问题：我的行业甚至会在乎什么明星员工吗？你知道的，对于我这种专业水平、成本这么高的人来说，真的存在市场吗？还是说“差不多就行了”？在为这本书做研究的过程中，我变得非常愤世嫉俗，答案往往是“差不多就行了”，这就是为什么你没有得到你想要的东西。但这其实全都是关于爱着一样东西，而它却无法给予你那些你觉得你付诸于这份工作或职业的回报。我们真的应该期望爱上我们的工作吗？我的意思是，毕竟这只是工作，而且我们在工作之外还有
relationships outside of work. But, you know, is that putting too much importance on something that is basically, you know, it's giving you the money to live and work and put a roof over your head and eat food? I love this question. So the first answer is absolutely not. It is not necessary to be in love with your job. When it becomes an issue is when you are in an industry or you're working for a company that expects that level of identity commitment, where everyone who thrives there is in love with their job and they see it as a core part of who they are and you maybe don't actually have that same kind of relationship with your career, that mismatch is where things start to go awry. Or you want to be in love with your job, but you don't know how to get it. I do think that kind of the matching
工作之外的人际关系。但是，你知道，这会不会是对一件本质上只是给你提供金钱来生活、工作、遮风挡雨和买食物的东西赋予了过高的重要性？我非常喜欢这个问题。所以，第一个答案是：绝对不。爱上工作并不是必须的。当它成为一个问题时，是因为你身处一个行业，或者在一家期望那种程度的身份承诺的公司工作，在那里，所有蓬勃发展的人都热爱他们的工作，并将其视为自我核心的一部分，而你可能并没有与你的职业建立那种关系，这种不匹配才是事情开始出问题的地方。或者你想爱上你的工作，却不知道该如何做到。我确实认为那种匹配的
component is really key. But I also think it's important for us to remember that our relationship with our career, we spend more time in that relationship than we do in our relationships at home. Just literal hours of the day, more of them are spent at work than they are at home. And, you know, I do a lot of research on stress contagion, how the stress we feel at work can be caught by our family members, by our friends. And the direction tends to go from work to home. That's the stronger direction of stress contagion than home to work. And it's because we spend more time at our jobs, and we do, even with our children, you know, even raising a child or with a loved one. And so I do think it's important to really try to grapple with how much you want to be in love
成分非常关键。但我也认为，有一点对我们来说很重要，那就是要记住，我们与职业的关系——我们花在这段关系里的时间，比我们在家里的关系里花的时间还要多。仅仅从字面上的每天的小时数来看，我们在工作上花的时间比在家里的时间还要多。而且，你知道的，我做了很多关于压力传染的研究，即我们在工作中感受到的压力是如何被我们的家人、朋友所传染的。这种方向往往是从工作到家庭。这是比从家庭到工作更强烈的压力传染方向。这是因为我们在工作上花的时间更多，甚至超过了我们陪伴孩子的时间，甚至超过了我们陪伴所爱之人的时间。因此，我确实认为，认真努力去应对你想对那个东西倾注多少爱
with that thing, but not underestimating the extent to which your negative emotions around it can actually affect other types of your life that you do really care about. Now, you mentioned in the introduction to the book that you've noticed a shift in recent years, especially post-pandemic and how people were thinking about and talking about their relationship with their work. Can you talk about that and how much of that shift do you think is due to the pandemic? Yes, I think, you know, we first saw this rise of kind of, you know, global unhappiness of onwee, of angst around our careers, rising during the pandemic. But I felt like during the pandemic, it was much easier for us to kind of finger point and blame it on the stress we were feeling from working from home.
是很重要的，但同时也不要低估它所带来的负面情绪实际上会影响到你真正在乎的其他类型的生活。现在，你在书的引言中提到，你注意到近年来发生了一个转变，特别是在大流行之后，人们思考和谈论他们与工作关系的方式发生了变化。你能谈谈这一点吗？你认为这种转变有多少是由大流行引起的？是的，我认为，你知道的，我们最早看到这种全球性不幸福感的兴起，这种对职业的厌倦和焦虑情绪，是在大流行期间开始上升的。但我觉得在大流行期间，我们更容易把矛头指向我们因居家办公而感受到的压力，并将其归咎于此。
The stress of, you know, the global economy catch, just crashing, people sick, you know, that, The pandemic was a very easy sort of blame for people who are experiencing workplace unhappiness. But you fast forward a few years, and here we are, and people are still miserable. Gallup just came out with a poll showing that, you know, 19% of people are just incredibly unhappy at work. But we don't quite have the same sort of source to blame it on. And I think for a lot of people, there's sort of this nebulous feeling that they're miserable and they're not quite sure why.
全球经济崩溃、人们生病等带来的压力，对于经历职场不快的人来说，大流行是一个非常容易找到的替罪羊。但几年过去了，我们现在身处这样的现实中，人们依然痛苦不堪。盖洛普（Gallup）刚刚发布了一项民意调查显示，19% 的人在工作中感到极其痛苦。但我们没有了同样明显的罪魁祸首来归咎。并且我认为，对于许多人来说，有一种模糊的感觉，觉得自己很痛苦，却又说不清原因。
You hear people sort of use causal language, like once our company merged with another one, everything fell apart, or once we got rid of our in office, our brick and mortar office, communication was no longer good, or my boss moved. So they're grappling with trying to sort of blame their unhappiness on a particular source, but they're not often sort of figuring out that that source is really their own kind of psychological relationship with their career, that it's actually kind of much deeper than just, a new boss or a new office, it isn't so much these structural things, but these kind of deep psychological issues. And that's kind of the shift that I've seen in the last couple years since the pandemic.
你会听到人们使用因果关系的语言，比如“自从我们公司跟另一家公司合并后，一切都崩溃了”，或者“自从我们取消了办公室、实体办公室后，沟通就不好了”，或者“我的老板调走了”。因此，他们费力地试图将自己的不快乐归咎于某个特定的根源，但他们往往没有弄明白，这个根源其实是他们自己对职业的心理关系，其实比单纯的一个新老板或新办公室要深得多，问题不在于这些结构性的东西，而在于这些深层的心理问题。这就是我自大流行以来在过去几年里看到的转变。
When people are feeling dissatisfied with their jobs and they start to think about leaving, I mean, you talked about five key drivers. Is it always, is it just one or is it always just a multiplicity of drivers? That's a really good question. I think for most of us, there's a lot going on. I think, you know, I created a survey to help you figure out what driver most strongly resonates with you, but almost everyone who I studied has at least two or three. I think almost everyone feels, you know, spread too thin at work. So I think the key is identifying sort of what is the main driver. And then from there, what are the kind of secondary order drivers that are going on?
当人们对工作感到不满并开始考虑离职时——我的意思是，你谈到了五个关键驱动因素。这通常只是一个驱动因素，还是总是多种驱动因素共同作用的结果？这是一个很好的问题。我认为对我们大多数人来说，情况很复杂。我想，你知道的，我创建了一个调查问卷来帮助你弄清楚哪个驱动因素对你的触动最深，但我研究的几乎每个人都有至少两三个。我认为几乎所有人都觉得自己在工作中分身乏术。所以，我认为关键在于确定什么是主要的驱动因素。然后在此基础上，再去了解同时存在的次要驱动因素是什么。
The only real choice point I think you have to make, at least in reading my book, is figuring out if you want a new job or a completely new career. That's kind of one of those big psychological questions that you need to grapple with. But most of us have a lot going on in terms of those psychological drivers for sure. Let's shift gears for a minute and talk about your first book, Jerks at Work, which is a great title. You identified five different types of jerks at work. Can you briefly, if that's possible, describe them and what their character traits are? Yes. So the first is the kiss-up kick-downer. So if anyone's ever worked in a place where they have a colleague who, you know, really mistreats people at the same level as them or beneath them,
我认为你唯一真正需要做的选择，至少在阅读我的书时，是弄清楚你是想要一份新工作还是一个全新的职业。这可以说是你需要应对的那些重大心理问题之一。但就那些心理驱动因素而言，我们大多数人的情况确实都挺复杂的。让我们换个话题，聊聊你的第一本书《职场中的混蛋》，这是一个很棒的书名。你在书中指出了五种不同类型的职场混蛋。你能简要地（如果可能的话）描述一下他们以及他们的性格特征吗？好的。第一种是“拍马屁踩底层者”（kiss-up kick-downer）。所以，如果有人曾在这样一个地方工作过：他们有一个同事，你知道的，对和他们同级别或比他们地位低的人非常虐待，
but the boss loves this person. They're high performer. You know this sort of a nerving feeling of not being able to get ahead because someone's blocking you who is just adored by people high status. And, you know, the kiss-up kickdowner, I think is a common experience, especially in pretty kind of cut-throat careers that a lot of us, you know, have been in. I worked in shoes, I worked in sales, and this is where I identified this person in academia. There's plenty of kiss-up, kick-downers. But I think there's other types of people that we deal with that are difficult. You know, there's bulldozers at work. The people who don't just kind of talk the whole time in a meeting, but actually go behind the scenes to leverage their status and power to disrupt group
但老板却很喜欢这个人。他们是高绩效员工。你会有一种让人不安的感觉，觉得由于有人在阻挠你，而这个人又备受高层喜爱，导致你无法高升。而且，你知道的，“拍马屁踩底层者”这种经历很常见，尤其是在我们许多人曾身处的那种相当残酷无情的职业中。我曾在鞋业工作过，我曾在销售行业工作过，正是在那里我认出了这种人。在学术界，也有很多“拍马屁踩底层者”。但我觉得我们还要应付其他类型招人烦的人。你知道，职场中还有“推土机”（bulldozers）。这种人不仅在开会时喋喋不休地抢话说，还会私底下利用自己的地位和权力去破坏团队的
processes. We see this a lot with things like hiring committees where they just keep ending in an impasse and they're not quite sure why. It turns out a bulldozer is talking to the boss or the boss's boss and saying, I don't like the process here because their candidate wasn't chosen, these kind of clever tricksy moves that they do. We also have credit stealers at work, people who will maybe give you credit for small things in an attempt to look like a team player, but they actually are taking credit for the bigger things.
进程。我们在招聘委员会之类的事情上经常看到这种情况，他们总是陷入僵局，却又说不清原因。结果发现，原来是某个推土机在跟老板或大老板谈话，说：“我不喜欢这里的流程”，因为他们心仪的候选人没被选上，这就是他们所玩弄的那些聪明的、狡猾的把戏。我们职场中还有“抢功劳者”（credit stealers），这些人可能会为你做的小事归功于你，以此来表现得像个团队合作者，但实际上他们把大事的功劳据为己有。
And I think it's very difficult for us to kind of know how much credit we deserve. Most of us think we deserve most of it. So allocating credit, figuring out that process is kind of one of the main issues around that one. And then I also talk about free writing, which is just ubiquitous. Everyone's been on a team with freewriters. One thing a lot of us don't realize is freewriters tend to be well-liked, well-connected people who brings something to the team. Often it's, you know, gossip or fun or the ability to get dinner reservations, something that acts as a social glue in the group. And for that reason, they're able to
而且我认为我们很难弄清楚自己究竟该得多少功劳。我们大多数人觉得自己该得大部分。所以分配功劳、弄清楚这个过程，正是围绕这一类型的主要问题之一。然后我还谈到了“搭便车者”（free riding），这简直无处不在。每个人都在有搭便车者的团队里待过。有一点我们很多人没有意识到，那就是搭便车者往往是讨人喜欢、人脉广阔、能为团队带来价值的人。通常是带来八卦、乐趣或是订到晚餐座位的本事，这些东西在团队中起到了社交黏合剂的作用。正因如此，他们才能够
kind of allocate all their work freely among all the other members and get away with it. I also talk about a couple different types of bosses, the micromanager, who most of us are probably also familiar with, that person who works all the time but gets nothing done. You know, I actually feel for these people. They often just receive poor training. And then And the other side of that is this neglectful boss. And often we actually see the two kind of going hand in hand. While I'm micromanaging you, I'm neglecting someone else. And that neglectful boss kind of goes in and out of caring. They show up at the 11th hour. They, you know, put their foot down. They demand changes and then they disappear again. And it's just a very sort of anxiety-provoking
将自己的工作轻而易举地分摊给所有其他成员，却还能逃脱惩罚。我还谈到了几种不同类型的老板，比如“微观管理者”（micromanager），大多数人可能也对此很熟悉，那种整天忙个不停却一事无成的人。你知道的，其实我很同情这些人。他们通常只是接受过糟糕的培训。然后，硬币的另一面是“甩手掌柜”（neglectful boss）。通常我们实际上会发现这两种倾向如影随形。当我在对你进行微管理时，我对另一个人却在疏忽。这种甩手掌柜在关心与不关心之间反复横跳。他们在最后一分钟才出现。他们，你知道的，态度强硬，
experience. And then I end with a gaslighter. And this is, you know, probably the most pathological of all the people I talk about. These individuals, lie with the intent of deceiving on a very big scale, often to cover something up or to get you to be involved in something that they don't want others knowing about. And the psychological damage that they do can last, you know, 10, 20, 30 years. And the victims of gaslighters often feel socially isolated and they feel like they don't know who they can go to for help. Out of all the types of Dursa I talk about, I think most of them are kind of accidental or unaware to some degree, with the exception of the first and the last.
要求改变，然后又消失了。这真是一种极易引发焦虑的体验。最后我以“煤气灯操纵者”（gaslighter）结尾。这是，你知道的，我所讨论的所有人中最具病态倾向的一类。这些人为了欺骗而撒谎，规模非常宏大，通常是为了掩盖某些事情，或者让你卷入他们不想让别人知道的事情中。他们造成的心理创伤可以持续，你知道的，10 年、20 年、30 年。而且受害者往往会感到被社会孤立，觉得不知道该向谁求助。在我讨论的所有类型的混蛋中，我认为他们大多数在某种程度上是无意的或没有意识到的，除了第一种和最后一种。
that gas lighter and that kiss-up kickdowner. They tend to actually be acting out in kind of self-interested ways. Others, maybe not so much. Which raises the question, and I know you get asked this all the time, but how do you know that you're not the jerk at work? Well, don't expect anyone to tell you if you are the jerk at work. One of the things I study a lot is feedback and how terrible we are at it and how anxious it makes us to be forthcoming. And so I think for a lot of jerks, they have to learn to read the tea leaves in interesting ways. I think kind of one of the kind of more interesting ways that they learn about this is when they apply for new jobs. And when that job seeks out recommendations or references, they get crickets in return. It's not that anyone says anything
那个煤气灯操纵者和那个拍马屁踩底层者。他们往往实际上是以一种利己的方式行事。其他人则未必如此。这就引发了一个问题——我知道总有人问你这个问题——但你如何知道自己不是职场中的那个混蛋呢？嗯，不要指望任何人会告诉你你是不是职场中的混蛋。我经常研究的一件事就是反馈，以及我们在反馈方面是多么糟糕，以及坦诚相待会让我们感到多么焦虑。所以我觉得对于很多混蛋来说，他们必须学会以有趣的方式去察言观色。我想其中一种更有趣的了解方式是当他们申请新工作时。而当那家工作单位去寻找推荐信或背调时，他们收到的只有蟋蟀叫声（一片死寂）。并不是说有人说了什么
bad. They just don't say anything good. And at NYU, I handle a lot of promotions among our professors. And we can tell if someone's a jerk when we solicit 20 letters and get two back for instance. Those are the kinds of clues. And so if you're worried about being a jerk, there is kind of a formula you need to follow of how to ask for very specific feedback, following anything you've done that isn't about your reputation, but more about your specific behaviors. But I do think that a lot of one-on-one coaching, and I do a lot of one-on-one coaching. And I find that people who are being coached because their boss thinks they're a jerk are just heartbroken when they find out that that's why they're in this meeting with me. You know, oh, I'm so excited for this leadership
坏话。他们只是什么好话都没说。在纽约大学，我处理过很多教授的晋升事宜。如果我们发出 20 封求证信却只收到 2 封回复，我们就能看出某人是不是个混蛋。这就是各种线索。所以如果你担心自己是个混蛋，你需要遵循一个公式来学习如何请求非常具体的反馈，这针对的是你做过的任何事情，但不是关于你的声誉，而是更多关于你的具体行为。但我确实认为，许多一对一辅导——我做很多一对一辅导。我发现那些因为老板认为他们是混蛋而接受辅导的人，当他们发现这就是他们来跟我开会的原因时，简直心碎欲绝。你知道的，“哦，我太期待这个领导力培训了”，而我的反应是：“这可不是什么领导力培训？我是来帮你‘戒掉混蛋行为’的。”而你的老板又不想告诉你，所以我只好代劳，欢迎来到这里听取这个消息。然后他们会哭泣，挺过去，然后，你知道的，我们就从那里继续前进。但这通常是一段相当揪心的经历。那么混蛋能被改造吗？是的，我认为，你知道的，并不是每个混蛋都能被改造，但总体而言，混蛋往往是从那些滋生并在这些情况下如鱼得水的系统和结构中成长起来的。你知道的，
training and I'm like, this is not a leadership training? I'm supposed to de-jerk you. And your boss didn't want to tell you, so here I am welcome to deliver the news for you. And then they cry and get over it and then, you know, we move on from there. But it's often a pretty heart-wrenching experience. And can jerks be rehabilitated? Yes, I think that, you know, not every jerk can be rehabilitated, but by and large, jerks tend to grow out of systems and structures that are, you know, in place to help sort of thrive in those situations. You know, there's, there are kind of hierarchies at work that are zero sum where kissup,
职场中存在着零和博弈的等级制度，拍马屁踩底层者只有通过这种方式才能出头。他们是马基雅维利式的。他们之前的所有成功者也都是马基雅维利式的。当你还在强化那种行为时，你还能指望什么呢？所以当老板和类似的人试图用“打地鼠”的方式来对付他们公司的混蛋时，我通常会叫他们停下来。去看看你们现有的系统和结构，看看你们的面试问题，看看你们的入职培训，你们是不是在做一些允许混蛋在这里滋生的事情。什么是企业文化？我知道这是一个宏大而模糊的词，但归根结底就是：你们的流程和程序是否在无意间为混蛋创造了一个肥沃的滋生土壤？
kickdowners can only get ahead by doing that. They're Machiavellian. Everyone who's made it before them was also Machiavellian. And what do you expect when you are reinforcing that kind of thing? And so I think when bosses and people like that try to play whackamol with their jerks, I usually tell them to stop. Look at the systems and structures you have in place and look at your interview questions and look at your onboarding and are you doing things to allow jerks to thrive here. What is the culture? And I know that's a big nebulous word, but it comes down to like what are your processes and procedures that are inadvertently creating a fertile breeding ground for jerks.
为此，我认为，是的，通过改变结构和系统，大多数人是可以被改造的。你有没有重新摆放过家具，然后发现地毯下面看起来全新，而其余部分看起来……嗯，没那么新？是时候升级地毯了。在全国家得宝（The Home Depot），我们有来自各大品牌的时尚选择，价格实惠。最棒的是，我们可以为你安装，每平方英尺仅需 49 美分起。所以你只需挑选你完美的地面。今天就在全国家得宝开启你的地毯翻新项目吧。实干者成就更多。
So to that end, I think, yes, most can be by changing structures and systems. Have you ever rearranged your furniture and discovered the carpet underneath looks brand new, while the rest of it looks, well, not so new? It's time for a carpet upgrade. At the Home Depot, we have stylish choices at simple prices from all the top brands. Best of all, we can install it for you, starting at only 49 cents per square foot. So all you have to do is pick your perfect floor. Start your carpet project today at the Home Depot. How doers get more done.
许可限制适用，请参见 Home Depot.com slash 许可证编号。那么，对于可能正在面试新工作的听众，他们能做些什么来确保自己不会步入一个充斥着混蛋的职场，或者更进一步，不仅仅是为了避开负面因素，而是步入一个他们认为自己可能会爱上这份工作的职场？这是一个很好的问题。我认为你可以做的、并且你自己能掌控的唯一一件事，就是尽可能多地与在该组织工作过的人交谈，不一定非得是你这个角色或你这个团队的人，而是组织中平行部门的人，包括过去和现在的员工。你知道的，在《工作疗法》一书中，
Exclusions apply for licenses, see Home Depot.com slash license numbers. So for a listeners who might be interviewing for a new job, what can they do to make sure that they're not walking into a workplace that's populated by jerks or to take it beyond the negative walking into a workplace where they think they might fall in love? This is a great question. I think that the single thing that you can do that you have control over is to speak to as many people as you can who work in that organization, not necessarily in your role or on your team, but in kind of parallel parts of the organization, past and present. You know, in job therapy,
我谈到了很多关于人脉网络（networking）的内容，对人们来说这似乎是个令人厌恶的词。但人脉网络其实归结为信息搜集。这意味着学习新的东西。这意味着了解通常在你真正入职之前不会体验到的职场中的隐性课程和规范。我们大多数人只与招聘经理对接。我们其实并没有问招聘经理：“我可以和在这家组织工作的团队成员谈谈吗？”如果你不知道该对他们说什么，因为你担心他们不会说任何关于该组织的坏话，你可以问一个简单的问题，那就是：填空。在我开始这份工作之前，没有人告诉我……。然后你会得到各种各样关于隐性规范、期望、
I talk a lot about networking, which feels like a yucky word for people. But networking really comes down to information gathering. It means learning new things. It means learning hidden curriculum and norms around a workplace that normally you wouldn't experience until you're already working there. Most of us only interface with hiring managers. We don't actually ask hiring managers, is can I talk to team members, you know, who work in this organization? And if you don't know what to say to them, because you're afraid they're not going to say anything bad about the organization, just you can ask one simple question, which is, finish the sentence. Before I started this job, nobody told me that. And you will get all kinds of fascinating answers around hidden norms, around expectations, around
角色的迷人回答。我调查了许多人并问了他们这个问题。大部分的回答都归结为作为角色一部分、但从未被宣传过的事情——无论是在招聘广告中还是在讨论中都没有提及——以及职场中人际动态的规范，为了晋升而被期望做的事情，被期望交谈的人，被期望如何互相尊重的方式，所有这些杂乱有趣的人际动态，而那一个问题将照亮整个组织的工作环境到底是怎样的。当你做这种功课时，我只想问问其中一些网站，比如像 Glassdoor 这样的地方。你觉得去那里值得吗？还是说那只是那些非常沮丧和心怀不满的人宣泄情绪的地方？
roles. I surveyed lots of people and asked them this question. And most of the answers came down to things that they were expected to do as part of the role that were not advertised ever, not in the job advertisement, not were discussed, and norms around interpersonal dynamics at work, things that they were expected to do to get ahead, people they were expected to talk to, ways that they are expected to respect one another, all of these kinds of messy, fun, interpersonal dynamics, and that one question will shed a whole bunch of light on what an organization is actually like to work for. When you're doing that kind of homework, I just want to ask about some of these websites, places like Glass Door, for example. Do you think it's worth going there? Or is that just a place for people who are really upset and disgruntled to let it all out?
Glassdoor 很像教授们的教学评估。你会得到两种答案。我喜欢这里。这里太棒了。我讨厌这里。这里太糟糕了。那些处在幸福感分布中间的人——觉得还行，不算太好——
Glassdoor is a lot like teaching evaluations for professors. You will get two answers. I love it here. It's wonderful. I hate it here. It's terrible. People who are in the middle of the distribution of happiness who are, it's fine. It's not great.
他们往往不会在 Glassdoor 上打分。从 Airbnb 到亚马逊，再到，你知道的，作为一名教授，我得到的教学评估，所有这类评分都是如此。所以你要知道，如果你在阅读 Glassdoor 上的那些内容，你得到的其实是一个相当有偏见的样本。你得到的是狂热的爱戴者和愤怒的痛恨者。你所不知道的是，这些爱戴者和痛恨者对在那里工作的一般人群到底有多大代表性。你知道的，如果有五个负面评价，这是否意味着 50% 的人都很痛苦，而你得到了一个很好的样本？还是说这意味着只有百分之一的人痛苦？你也不知道这些人是否都彼此有联系，你实际得到的其实是通过五个声音表达的一种体验，还是代表不同问题的五种独特体验。我想，你知道的，任何时候你与职场中的人建立人脉，你都能够摸清这里面有多少是由于，比如说，一个共同的老板，或者一个，你知道的，拥有糟糕文化的过去办公室所致，而不是个人独特的体验。所以，这就是一对一对话能带给你的、超越 Glassdoor 的价值。我知道人们喜欢看评分，并对它们进行过分解读。这是一种被动的体验。这是一种没有焦虑的体验。与人交谈更难。它更让人不舒服。它更尴尬。但当你这样做时，你得到的数据却没那么丰富。不愧是科学家。
They tend to not put ratings on Glassdoor. And this is true for all kinds of ratings from Airbnb to Amazon to, you know, as a professor, the teaching evaluations I get. And so just know that if you're reading. those things on Glassdoor, you're getting a pretty biased sample. You're getting the lovers and the haters. What you don't know is how representative those lovers and haters are of the general group of people who work there. You know, if there's five negative reviews, does that mean that 50% of the people who are miserable and you're getting that a good selection? Or does that mean one percent are miserable? You also don't know whether those people are all networked with
是的。现在，美国心理学协会最近发布了我们的年度“美国工作”调查，该调查关注人们对职场和工作生活的感受。今年出现的一个主要主题是关于职场心理安全感，即那些感到心理安全的人在职业生涯中更有满足感和幸福感。我很好奇你对此有何反应？心理安全感文化能否遏制混蛋行为，并真正使其更像是一个你会感到快乐并坠入爱河的职场？我一直在用这个比喻。抱歉。是的，抱歉。你现在陷入了对职业生涯坠入爱河的困境中。我把它强加给你了。
each other and what you're actually getting as one experience through five voices or five unique experiences that are all representative of a different problem. And I think, you know, any time you network with people at work, you're able to kind of suss out how much of this is due to, say, a common boss or, you know, a past office that had a bad culture versus kind of individual experiences. And so that's what one-on-one conversations will give you above and beyond Glass Door. I know people love rating, reading ratings and reading a lot into them. It's a passive experience. It's an anxiety-free experience. Talking to people is harder. It's more uncomfortable. It's more awkward. But it's just less rich data that you're getting when you do that. Spoken like a scientist.
而你再也无法用别的方式来看待工作了，就像一个我没有选择的浪漫伴侣一样。是的，我认为心理安全感是一个非常有趣的概念，这是我们许多人——尤其是 Z 世代和千禧一代——所喜爱的一个概念。我确实认为，当我们思考时，我们需要对营造心理安全感所需的条件持一点批判态度，因为我认为有大量研究表明人们重视心理安全感，但他们发现威胁到它的往往是诸如清晰的、批判性的反馈之类的事情，你知道的，因为他们还没有完全为此培养出心理承受能力，或者因为他们的组织还没有向他们展示以心理安全的方式传达和接收该反馈的正确方法。
Yep. Now, APA recently published our annual work in America survey, which looks at how people are feeling about their workplaces and their work lives. And one of the major themes that came out this year was around psychological safety at work, the idea that people who feel psychologically safe are more satisfied and happier in their careers. I'm curious about how you react to that. Can a culture of psychological safety deter jerkiness and really make it more of a workplace where you will be happy and fall in love? I keep using that metaphor. Sorry. Yeah, sorry. You're trapped now with falling in love with your career. I've forced it on you. and now you're never going to be able to think about a job another way is like a romantic partner
所以我认为这个概念超级重要，你会希望觉得如果从老板那里得到负面反馈，或者甚至向上级老板反馈时，你在社交上不会因此面临负面影响。一个组织要同时做到这两件事需要付出很多努力：给你批判性反馈，给你成功所需的东西，帮你建立人脉，同时还让你感到安全。我是读了美国心理学协会的压力报告后说这番话的，该报告显示，Z 世代和千禧一代的焦虑感和压力感已经爆表，他们因为这些事情而辞职的可能性也很高。所以我确实认为我们需要稍微调和一下这个矛盾。我们需要弄清楚
that I did not choose that. Yes, I think psychological safety is a really interesting concept and it's one that a lot of us, especially Gen Z and millennials love. I do think that when we think we need to be a little critical about what it takes to be psychologically safe because I think there's a lot of work showing that people value psychological safety, but what they find that threatens it is often things like clear, critical feedback, you know, because they haven't quite developed the muscle for it or because their organization hasn't shown them the right way of delivering and receiving that feedback in a psychologically
如何在人们在工作中感到压力和焦虑的同时，创造心理安全感，而他们同时也需要那种负面反馈——不是负面，而是批判性反馈、具体反馈——来向前发展。这有很多复杂的概念，同时在运作，我认为我们确实需要做一些工作来弄清楚如何让它们齐心协力地发挥作用。我们从该调查的数据中得出的另一个结论是，职场中正在发生代际问题，我们可能正处于历史上从未有过的境地：一个单一的职场中可能有多达五代人同时存在。
safe way. So I think the concept is super important and you want to feel like if you get negative feedback from your boss or you give it even upward to a boss that you're not going to face negative repercussion socially for it. It takes a lot of work for an organization to be able to do both things at once. Give you that critical feedback, give you what you need to succeed, help you network, and also make you feel safe at the same time. And I'm saying this having read APA's kind of stress report, which shows that Gen Z and millennials are through the roof and how anxious they're feeling, how stress they're feeling, and then the likelihood that they're going to quit a job because of those things. And so I do think we kind of need to square that circle a little bit. We need to figure out
我们发现年轻人与年长者的相处并不融洽。你在工作中也看到了这样的情况吗？是的，绝对是的。而且我认为，你知道的，我们可以把这场对话引向很多不同的方向。我们看到婴儿潮一代（boomers）的退休潮中出现了这种情况，缺乏退休的紧迫感。我认为年长一代彼此沟通的方式与年轻一代彼此沟通的方式有很大不同。年长一代更喜欢面对面沟通，如果行不通则打电话。他们不喜欢，你知道的，Zoom 会议、Slack 频道以及那些提供较少信息的沟通渠道。他们喜欢更频繁的互动，而不是形式化的互动。
how we can create psychological safety while people are stressed and anxious at work, and while they also need that negative feedback to kind of move forward. Not negative, but critical feedback, specific feedback to actually move forward. And it's a lot of kind of complex concepts, kind of all being, you know, working at one time that I think we do need to do some work to figure out how to make them all kind of work in unison. another conclusion that that we reached looking at the data from that survey was that there are issues intergenerational issues in the workplace that are happening right now and we're probably for the first time ever in a situation where there can be as many as five generations in a single
最重要的是，他们更喜欢你当面找他们对质，而不是在 TikTok 上做，而不是公开做。我认为在对质、对这些事情的舒适度方面存在规范上的差异，其中许多差异源于我们在各代人中看到的焦虑差异和心理健康问题。我认为年长一代对在工作中使用生成式 AI 的适应度较低。他们想要一种更自然、更像人类的、通过图灵测试的那种体验。而且我认为，你知道的，在这场对话中我们做得不够的一件事，就是讨论年长一代拥有什么比年轻一代更好的东西。他们的焦虑更少。他们拥有更丰富的社交网络。他们拥有隐性
workplace we're finding that the younger folks are not relating well to the people who are older are you seeing things like this as well in your work yes absolutely and I think you know we could take this conversation in so many directions. I think we're seeing it with retirements among boomers, a lack of urgency to retire. I think the ways in which older generations prefer to communicate with one another are very different than the ways in which younger generations prefer to communicate. Older generations prefer face-to-face communications, phone calls if that can't work out. They don't like, you know, Zoom calls, Slack channels, those kind of communication channels that give you less information. They perform more frequent interactions, not formal interactions.
知识和指导经验，而这些我们经常随手抛弃，说：“为什么你们不能直接离开？为什么你们不能直接退休，给年轻人腾出地方？”我认为这是一个巨大的错失良机。为婴儿潮一代辩护，我真的认为，你知道的，这是一个错失的、本可以丰富沟通的机会。我这样说是在明知 AI 正在接管许多工作的前提下，但它没有接管的是人机交互的工作，比如酒店业、医疗保健业、那些需要你与另一个人进行良好沟通的事情。而年长一代实际上往往要好得多
And above all else, they prefer you to confront them face to face, not to do it on TikTok, not to do it publicly. And I think there are norm differences around confrontation, around comfort around these things, a lot of which are rising from these anxiety differences that we're seeing in generations and mental health issues. And I think the older generations are less comfortable with things like generative AI being used at work. They want a more sort of organic human, you know, pass the touring test kind of experience. And I think, you know, one thing that we're not doing a lot in this conversation is talking about what older generations have that is better than younger generations. They are less anxious. They have richer social networks. They have tacit
最重要的是，他们更喜欢你当面与他们对质，而不是在TikTok上，也不是公开进行。我认为，围绕对质以及对这些事情的舒适度，存在着规范上的差异，其中很大一部分源于我们在不同代际和心理健康问题中看到的焦虑差异。我认为，年长一代对在工作中使用生成式AI等事情感到不太自在。他们希望有一种更自然、更有人情味、你知道的，能通过图灵测试的那种体验。而且我认为，你知道的，我们在这次对话中做得不够多的一件事，就是讨论年长一代比年轻一代更优秀的地方。他们没那么焦虑。他们拥有更丰富的社交网络。他们拥有隐性
knowledge and experience with mentorship that we often kind of throw aside and say, why can't you just leave? Why can't you just retire and make room for the younger people? And I think that it's a huge missed opportunity there. In defense of the boomers, I really do think, you know, it's a missed, and Gen Xers, it's a missed opportunity to actually enrich in communication. And I say this knowing that AI is taking over a lot of jobs, but what it's not taking over, the human interfacing ones, things like hospitality, healthcare, things that require you to communicate well with another person. And older generations tend to actually be much
知识以及指导经验，而我们经常把这些抛在一边，说：“你为什么不直接离开？你为什么不早点退休，给年轻人腾出位置？”我认为这是一个巨大的错失良机。为婴儿潮一代辩护，我真的认为，你知道的，这是一个错失的机遇——对于X世代来说也是如此——错失了真正丰富沟通的机遇。我说这话的同时，也知道AI正在接管许多工作，但它无法接管的是那些需要人际交往的工作，比如酒店业、医疗保健业，以及那些需要你与另一个人良好沟通的事情。而年长一代实际上往往要
better at that than younger generation. So, you know, I'm all about like, let's bring that knowledge in to kind of help solve some of these intergenerational issues that we're seeing at work. So I want to switch topics to exit interviews. I read an article in which you said that the default response in exit interviews is to lie is bold. And I'm wondering then, is there any value to exit interviews. And if you're the exit interviewee, what's the best way to handle an exit interview and make it worth everyone's time? Yes, I think that I'm pretty sure you're referencing this Wall Street Journal article I wrote about it all the lies. We tell it work, all the ways in which we lie. Exit interviews, when they're often framed from a hires or organizational perspective,
比年轻一代做得更好。所以，你知道，我全力主张，让我们把这些知识带进来，以帮助解决我们在工作中看到的这些代际问题。因此，我想把话题转向离职面谈。我读过你的一篇文章，你在其中提到，离职面谈中的默认反应是说谎，这很大胆。我想知道，离职面谈还有价值吗？如果你是接受离职面谈的人，处理离职面谈并让它物有所值、不浪费大家时间的最好方法是什么？是的，我想我敢肯定你指的是我写的那篇关于我们所说的一切谎言的《华尔街日报》文章，我们工作时说的一切谎言，我们说谎的种种方式。离职面谈，当它们通常从招聘方或组织的角度出发时，
It's a, it's a, it's HR person asking you why you're leaving, often in these kind of broadways that don't get at specific issues you might have faced. And if you are to be completely honest, there could be a major sort of loss to your reputation and status. And so what organizations aren't thinking about is what would this person have to gain by being honest? Why would they want to tell the truth? And, you know, what, if you're never going to talk to these people again, why would you sort of
这通常是HR人员问你为什么要离开，通常是用那种无法触及你可能面临的具体问题的宏观方式。如果你完全诚实，你的声誉和地位可能会受到重大损失。因此，组织没有考虑到的是，这个人通过诚实能得到什么？他们为什么要说实话？而且，你知道，如果你再也不会和这些人说话了，你为什么要那种
give them that kind of feedback. So I think if you want honest answers, you can't wait first until the exit interview to actually ask those questions. And if you're the employee, you need to insist that these questions are asked at multiple stages during your time there. I actually don't think it's up to the employee to be honest in these interviews unless they're given an incentive to do so. Many of them are going to rely on these places to give them recommendations for the future and it's harming their reputations, to be honest. So if you want honest answers, ask very specific questions that would be difficult to lie about. If you want, you know, friendly overtures, ask, how was your time here?
给予他们那种反馈。所以我想，如果你想要诚实的答案，你不能等到离职面谈时才去问这些问题。如果你是员工，你需要坚持在你在那里的各个阶段都提出这些问题。实际上，我认为不应该由员工在这些面谈中保持诚实，除非给他们这样做的动力。他们中的许多人将依靠这些地方为他们提供未来的推荐信，说实话会损害他们的声誉。因此，如果你想要诚实的答案，问一些很难说谎的具体问题。如果你想要，你知道，友好的姿态，问，你在这里过得怎么样？
How was your boss? You know, things that are so vague, they could really mean anything. And you're just going to get a lot of head nods and smiles and say, I just had a better opportunity elsewhere without the truth. Because you haven't been asking for the truth the entire time that they were here. As the famous saying goes, you can't handle the truth. Yeah, they also don't. I'll add one other thing.
你的老板怎么样？你知道，这些问题太含糊了，它们实际上可以指任何事情。你只会得到很多点头和微笑，然后说，我在别处得到了一个更好的机会，而没有说出真相。因为在他们待在这里的整个过程中，你都没有在寻求真相。正如那句名言所说，你承受不起真相。是的，他们也没有。我再补充一点。
A lot of organizations don't have a plan of what they actually do with exit interview data. They sort of collect it. You don't know what they're going to do with that. Are they going to give it to your boss? Are they going to just stick it in a file and never look at it again? You need to be transparent about what you're actually using these data for and, you know, tell people that so that they have some sense of what their information is being used for. Now, your academic research is about interpersonal communication.
许多组织没有计划好他们实际上将如何处理离职面谈的数据。他们只是收集它。你不知道他们会用它做什么。他们会把它交给你老板吗？他们会把它塞进文件夹再也不看一眼吗？你需要对你实际使用这些数据的用途保持透明，你知道，告诉人们这一点，以便他们对自己的信息被如何使用有一个概念。现在，你的学术研究是关于人际交往的。
and miscommunication in many different settings and situations, not just at work, but why is it important for people to think about the potential for miscommunication on the job? So I think most of us are worse communicators than we realize, partly because we have a major kind of transparency bias that we think our thoughts and feelings are just going to be sort of readable to other people. There's a lot of reasons why that's not true. In fact, I spent 20 years trying to get people to be more accurate at reading one another in interpersonal interactions and in the workplace.
以及在许多不同环境和情况下的沟通不畅，不仅仅是在工作中，但为什么人们思考工作中沟通不畅的可能性很重要呢？所以我认为我们大多数人都比自己意识到的沟通能力要差，部分原因是我们有一种重大的透明度偏误，我们认为我们的想法和感觉对其他人来说是显而易见的。有很多原因导致事实并非如此。事实上，我花了20年时间试图让人们在人际互动和工作场所中更准确地解读彼此。
And the only magic bullet is to ask, what are you thinking? What did you mean by that? And I think a lot of us walk around at work kind of underestimating the value of clear, consistent communication in developing better skills at work, at learning how to perform at work. So everything from making small corrections early on in your career, like, a Matthew effect that will then help you grow later to understanding why you didn't get a raise or promotion. And I think kind of the most salient example I have from my book is in the runner-up chapter and job therapy. I think 7% of people are explicitly told why they were passed up for
而唯一的法宝就是问，你在想什么？你这话是什么意思？我认为我们很多人在工作时都低估了清晰、持续的沟通在培养更好的工作技能、学习如何在工作中表现方面的价值。因此，从职业生涯早期做出的小调整，比如马太效应，它会反过来帮助你以后的成长，到理解为什么你没有得到加薪或晋升。我认为我在书中最显著的例子是在替补章节和工作治疗中。我认为7%的人被明确告知了他们为什么被错过
promotion or raise. Most of them had to guess. And that is a huge communication gap. Whose fault is that? It's probably both people's fault. But I don't think it just comes down to one conversation you have at work. Why didn't I get promoted? It comes down to a thousand thousand small conversations you didn't have at work around what you're doing potentially right or wrong. So I think a lot of us underestimate the power of those small, daily organic conversations we have in helping us network and helping us figure out, you know, how to troubleshoot and how to move forward. And before you know it 20 years in, you just can't manage to get that next step up and you have no idea why. And it's, that's probably why. And, you know, and that's something that I think most of us
晋升或加薪。他们大多数人不得不靠猜测。这是一个巨大的沟通鸿沟。那是谁的错？这可能是两个人的错。但我认为这不仅仅归结于你在工作中进行的一次谈话：为什么我没有晋升？它归结于你在工作中没有进行的成千上万次关于你可能做得对或错的小型日常谈话。所以我认为我们很多人都低估了我们在帮助自己建立人脉、帮助自己弄清楚，你知道，如何排除故障以及如何前进方面所进行的那些微小的、日常的有机谈话的力量。在你意识到之前，20年已经过去了，你就是无法迈出下一步，你完全不知道为什么。而且，这可能就是原因。并且，你知道，这是我认为我们大多数人
underestimate. So just to wrap up, I like to ask this question sometimes to close. What are you working on? What are the next big questions you're trying to answer? What's your next book? Ooh. I lay a lot on you. Yeah. I mean, my lab is doing some really fascinating research of what happens when we work with people who we disagree with politically and who are moral violators. And I think one thing that's fascinating is looking at the difference between what people will say they'll do and what they actually do. And we're finding that, you know, a lot of us interact with people who we morally disagree with, politically disagree with. And we think that we're going to be pretty, you know, blunt in those interactions. But what we're finding is the opposite. The more immoral
都低估了的。所以总结一下，有时我喜欢用这个问题来收尾。你正在做什么？你试图回答的下一个重大问题是什么？你的下一本书是什么？哦。我给你抛出了很多问题。是的。我的意思是，我的实验室正在做一些非常迷人的研究，关于当我们与政治观点不合、以及是道德违背者的人一起工作时会发生什么。我认为迷人的一点是观察人们说他们会做什么与他们实际做什么之间的区别。我们发现，你知道，我们很多人都与我们在道德上不合、政治上不合的人互动。我们认为我们在这些互动中会相当，你知道，直言不讳。但我们发现恰恰相反。越是不道德
the person you're negotiating with, the nicer you are to them, the more likely you are to let them win that negotiation. And so some of these kinds of ironic effects of complex social processes, that can shape us at work in ways that we often aren't thinking about so much. I want to also do a lot of work on anxious leadership. I mentioned in this podcast, the APA has done a lot of work on documenting the levels of stress and negative well-being among millennial leaders, among Gen Ziers, are being led by those millennial leaders. And what the dynamic impacts are to have this whole generation of anxious leaders
你与之谈判的人，你对他们就越好，你就越有可能让他们赢得那场谈判。因此，复杂社会过程的其中一些讽刺效果，会以我们通常没有太多思考的方式塑造我们在工作中的表现。我还想做大量关于焦虑领导力的工作。我在这个播客中提到过，美国心理协会（APA）做了大量工作，记录了千禧一代领导者、以及由这些千禧一代领导者领导的Z世代员工中压力和消极幸福感的水平。拥有整整一代焦虑的领导者，会带来什么动态影响？
ushering in anxious direct reports and how that is then going to play out in the workplace. you know, to contrast them with baby boomers who are not anxious, who are direct communicators. What is that going to do for performance, for growth, for, you know, all of these kinds of complex processes? So looking at some of those cohort effects that we had talked about earlier. So those are some of the projects that I'm thinking about right now. Well, that's all really interesting. I look forward to seeing more of your research.
迎来了焦虑的直接下属，以及这随后将如何在职场中发挥作用。你知道，将他们与不焦虑、直言不讳的婴儿潮一代进行对比。那会对绩效、成长、你知道，所有这些复杂的流程产生什么影响？所以，看看我们之前讨论过的一些同代效应。这就是我目前正在考虑的一些项目。嗯，这真的非常有趣。我期待看到你更多的研究。
I want to thank you for joining me today. It's been very edifying. Thank you so much for having me on the show. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.w.combeingof Psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinemann.
我想感谢你今天加入我。这非常具有启发性。非常感谢邀请我参加这个节目。你可以在我们的网站 www.w.combeingof Psychology.org 上，或者在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或你获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》过往的节目。如果你喜欢你所听到的内容，请订阅并给我们留一条评论。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以给我们发电子邮件：speaking of psychology at APA.org。心理学谈话由李·韦内曼（Lee Weinemann）制作。
Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. Relax and let Ralph's delivery handle your grocery shopping this week. We start with only the freshest items, then review your list and carefully choose each one. Then we pack it all up and deliver it in as little as 30 minutes, so you can feel confident it's what you ordered. Fresh groceries, your way, with Ralph's delivery and pickup. And right now, you can save $20 on your first delivery or pickup order. Ralph's, fresh for everyone.
感谢收听，我是美国心理协会的金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。放松身心，让拉尔夫（Ralph's）配送服务来处理你本周的杂货采购。我们从最新鲜的商品开始，然后查看你的清单并仔细挑选每一件。接着，我们把所有东西打包好，最快30分钟内送达，让你确信这就是你订购的东西。新鲜杂货，按你的心意，尽在拉尔夫的配送与自提服务。现在，你的第一笔配送或自提订单还可以节省20美元。拉尔夫，为每个人保鲜。
Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可发表评论。